I think that if you make your bed every
day it makes such a big difference it
starts your day in this place where it's
like okay now I have like a you when we
first came here didn't have a job didn't
have a place to live
didn't have money it was just like
taking this crazy leap of faith I
literally wouldn't have been able to do
it without her because she offered me so
much emotional support there's a classic
story of my family that my dad hates
where he he like saw some of my
scribbles when I was really young and he
was like I don't know if David it's like
that good at drawing I've seen what the
other kids in this class are doing and I
don't know but I think I just loved it
and didn't stop
so keeping my passions alive ended up
giving me a career that I really like
most of the time people are either
worrying about the future or dwelling on
the past it's great to just kind of just
be here be in the moment and realize
like this is life
learn to love failing because it's how
you become you finding things that keep
you grounded for me it is having a dog
it is having someone that I have to show
up for and be accountable to don't talk
about it be about it don't go to bed
angry yeah drink a lot of water soft a
giant magical creature and wear
sunscreen
[Music]